can you still do that thing but then  with your voice I know what you mean you  can what you see with me is what you  care right I'm an idiot  jumpy I'm really sorry I'm very sorry  I've just just a little the drugs are  kicking in a minute yeah are you so cuz  when I was at school I was very shy I  mean I was I mean I had like fuzzy yeah  yeah I lived in Bristol I used to talk  like that  all right now are you doing the road  really facial twitch I used to go out he  had a twitch my best foot he was like I  saw you do this thing I used to sit  there because I sort of created my own  world and I'd sit there a teacher be on  the blackboard and I'd go I'd go  and eat the chicken who is that and I'd  go  just go  [Laughter]  [Applause]  [Music]